le pregunto entonces de nuevo cuáles
fueron los principales cambios que hizo
martín le pen y que pueden marcar o
puede significar un poco que esté a tan
sólo 5% de manuel mayor
pues efectivamente llega con múltiples
cambios llegará inventada con kilómetros
de kilómetros de terreno recorridos
haciendo campaña en las diferentes
ciudades de francia y además mejor
preparada como ella misma lo ha dicho
que en 2017 cuatro cambios importantes
para llegar al punto en el que está hoy
el primero es que suavizó su discurso en
esta azotar este tercera carrera al
elíseo que fue anunciada en el 2020 ha
querido deseen marcarse de ese fracaso
de las elecciones de 2017 y de 2012
mostrándose mucho más moderada más
cercana a menos agresiva pero radical en
temas de migración el segundo cambio
importante con el que llega marine lepén
es que ha centrado su discurso en las
necesidades de la gente en el poder
adquisitivo y precisamente aquí ella
quiere reducir el impuesto del iva que
está en este momento en 20% y bajarlo al
5,5 por ciento sobre todo en los
combustibles
y reducir quiere aumentar perdón el
salario mínimo y dejárselo a las
empresas que lo hagan con el 10%
mantener la edad de jubilación a los 62
años y por qué no a los 60 para aquellos
jóvenes que comiencen a trabajar antes
de los 20 años todo esto le ha valido
una visibilidad porque ha tocado temas
sociales que tocan el bolsillo de los
franceses el tercer cambio importante en
este recorrido que ha tenido marie le
pen es que reestructuró su partido le
cambió el nombre de frente nacional al
partido que creó su padre jean-marie le
pen en
1972 este ex combatiente de argelia y lo
creó con un nuevo nombre agrupación
nacional que nace en 2018 un año después
del fracaso de las elecciones de 2017
tratando de dejar de lado ese legado y
esa retórica de su padre asociada a una
tradición de la derecha anti republicana
antisemita anti musulmana y xenófoba
apartó también a miembros destacados del
frente nacional incluso sacó a su padre
de su propio partido
sin embargo agrupación nacional mantiene
la misma base de su discurso en el
nacionalismo como lo ha tenido como lo
tenía el frente nacional y el cuarto
punto ha sido la llegada de eriksson en
un principio marie le pen le señaló de
haberle robado varias ideas de
agrupación nacional pero seguramente
ahora tendrá mucho que agradecerle
porque la ha beneficiado de hecho
diferentes análisis publicados en medios
locales dan muestra que el epen nunca
había sido tan poco vista como de
extrema derecha como lo es ahora y eso
en parte se debe a ese discurso radical
antisemita y anti musulmán de eric
zemmour al partido de eric samur varios
de los militantes del antiguo frente
nacional se han ido incluso la sobrina
de marie le pen marion marichal